Це лише тест: клієнти зустрічають віртуального шопінг-асистента
А це - реальність: гроші - продавцеві,
товар - покупцеві
Саме в такому вигляді
досі переважно функціонує торгівля
Багато хто й досі розплачується
традиційно
паперовими грошима
Однак сферу торгівлі очікують значні зміни
Вже нині кожне восьме євро в Німеччині
припадає на онлайн
Технічні можливості стрімко розвиваються
А продавці?
Адже їх слід зовсім по-іншому навчати тонкощам продажу в інтернеті
Звісно, нам терміново потрібні експерти в цій галузі
У минулому ми працевлаштували
дуже багато випускників
і тих, хто перекваліфікувався
Але цього в майбутньому буде недостатньо
Тож ми вирішили, що мусимо терміново створити
освітні можливості для нової професії
З серпня такі курси вже пропонуються у Німеччині.
Це - перші спудеї
Я охоче працюю за комп'ютером
У цій сфері, звісно, існує
дуже багато освітніх напрямків
У майбутньому більшість
працюватиме за комп'ютером
Суспільство дедалі більше стає цифровим.
Онлайн-магазини стрімко розвиваються
Кожен купує щось в інтернеті
майже ніхто вже не йде в магазини
Тож мені це здалося дуже перспективним
Їхнє майбутнє завдання - розвивати та консультувати онлайн-магазини
Тут торгівля функціонує зовсім інакше
знижки, захист даних,
відсутність особистого контакту
Ми докладно бачимо, хто заходить на наш сайт
Яка вікова структура. Чоловіки чи жінки
Відповідно до цього може дуже добре оптимізувати свій онлайн-магазин
Важливий також, звісно, фактор сервісу
Чим простіше для клієнта - тим краще
А традиційні магазини?
Мають залишитися, але також обов'язково
пропонувати свої послуги онлайн
То де купують німці?
50 на 50
Я купую трохи більше в інтернеті,
але теж ходжу в магазин
Класичні продавці мають отримувати додаткові знання про онлайн-торгівлю
Найкраща стратегія - багатовекторність:
продаж і в магазинах, і в інтернеті
Якщо тестові продажі з онлайн-асистентом
пройдуть успішно
то в майбутньому можна буде робити кар'єру
і віртуального продавця